[Musica]
12 dicembre 1969
bomba di piazza fontana
diciassette persone sono morte molti di
questi erano agricoltori
uno di questi il più giovane aveva solo
33 anni questo era mio padre
nel 69
gli avevo tre anni mio fratello antonio
aveva due anni mia mamma navali aveva 28
anni
mio padre numeri non morì il giorno
dello scoppio bory ben sedici anni dopo
lo scoppio bruciò le sue gambe
tempi suo corpo di schegge gli fece
perdere l'udito e papà era comunque
totalmente inabile al lavoro
con papà in abile lavoro io fin da
piccolo con mio fratello mi dedicai alla
gestione della nostra azienda agricola
all'età di 13 14 anni io mio fratello
eravamo già due entusiasti felici
imprenditori ci piaceva fare
quell'attività di giorno lavoravano nei
campi e la sera giocavamo calcio nella
squadra del nostro paesello
eravamo in una sorta di zona di comfort
non chiedevamo nulla di più dalla vita
non chiedevo nulla di più tanto che io
non sentivo l'esigenza di studiare io
fui bocciato in prima ragioneria con il
7 in condotta
da ripetente io fui di un nuovo bocciato
io semplicemente non volevo studiare
volevo fare l'agricoltore
dopo la seconda bocciatura 15 anni la
mamma mi disse ve trovare papà chi vuole
parlare
preso la mia moto andai a trovarlo in
ospedale
mi chiamo vicino se mi disse
come puoi giovanni pensare
che nulla cambi oggi l'agricoltura ti dà
da vivere ma non sarà in eterno e
soprattutto come puoi affrontare una
vita senza un titolo di studio
che ho scritto
la mamma per la terza volta prima
ragioneria per favore studia nè tutte le
capacità fallo per me
pochi mesi dopo era l'ottobre del 1983
mio padre da quel letto spirò
a quel punto con un po di impegno e
probabilmente d'aiuto da parte della
scuola portò a casa quel pezzo di carta
ma nel frattempo io continuavo a
lavorare come fraterno nell'azienda
agricola e in quegli anni la tecnologia
e la meccanizzazione stava trasformando
il nostro business
e lì si rileverà la prima profezia di
mio padre
ogni anno erano necessari nuovi
investimenti in macchinari
l'azienda diventava sempre più piccola
serviva nuova terra noi non avevamo i
soldi
a quel punto prima io e poi mio fratello
fummo costretti a uscire dalle nostre
zone di sicurezza e reinventarci
la cosa curiosa della mia vita e che si
è vero la tecnologia allora distrutto il
mio primo sogno e oggi dopo 40 anni io
mi trovo a fare il manager della più
grossa della più grossa azienda di
tecnologie italiana
quando nel 2009 io entrai in questa
industria nel settore della tecnologia e
dell'informatica
lo percepivo come un settore al pari del
settore bancario del settore
farmaceutico di altri settori mi
sbagliavo
quello che ho capito lavorando in queste
in questa bellissima azienda e che la
tecnologia non è un settore la
tecnologia è trasversale e pervasiva non
ci oggi settore che non sia interessato
dalle grandi trasformazioni che la
tecnologia sta portando
qualche anno fa andai in america in
silicon valley a seguire una conferenza
sulle tecnologie esponenziale le
tecnologie del futuro
c'erano eravamo 3000 in quella sala da
tutto il mondo
c'erano bravissimi relatori bellissime
presentazioni con un certo punto sul
palco ci hanno presentato un timido
ragazzo messicano che faceva il
benzinaio in california
ricordo ancora nitidamente le sue parole
ci disse
guardate io faccio il benzinaio da tanti
anni
per anni tutti i weekend è abituato
avere circa 4.000 clienti che venivano
da me alla bara la macchina e fare il
pieno di benzina aveva anche il lavaggio
verso il 2010 la situazione è cambiata
improvvisamente non capivo il perché poi
parlando con i miei clienti l'ho capito
nel 2007 è nato lo smartphone nel 2010
gli smartphone si sono diffusi nelle
tasche di tutti i suoi clienti e questi
non facevano altro che pianificare in
anticipo weekend sulla base delle
previsioni del tempo curate che
trovavano sul loro smartphone e quindi
decidevano se lavare la macchina fare il
pieno in caso di tempo bello se starsene
comodamente seduti sul sofà di casa a
guardarsi la partita di football
americano di basket
capite perché la tecnologia e pervasiva
anche nel settore dove apparentemente
non entra le pompe di benzina sono
sempre le stesse la tecnologia cambi
comportamenti dei clienti di quel
settore trasforma i modelli di business
guardate lavoro in un'azienda
tecnologica quello che vi posso
assicurare è che quello che abbiamo
visto fino a oggi solo una piccola parte
di un cambiamento che sarà sempre più
esponenziale nel prossimo futuro
questa è choice
choice non è una persona è un avatar
dotata di intelligenza artificiale
ebbene oggi in cina choe gestisce
contemporaneamente i rapporti con
milioni di clienti ma soprattutto nello
stesso tempo riesce a scrivere cantare
canzoni scrive libri per ragazzi scrive
poesie gestisce un programma tv e
gestisce 18 trasmissioni radiofoniche
beh
pensate che choice prima o poi non
arriverà in europa in italia
pensate che quello che è successo ma nel
settore agricolo non succederà in altri
settori o nel vostro settore
cosa possiamo fare
ricordo la mia prima reazione quando era
il ri colture al cambiamento la
resistenza ma perché dobbiamo cambiare
non possiamo aspettare un attimo
so se vi ricordate al fine degli anni 90
i tanti gli amici che ri colto ricche
hanno bloccato all'aeroporto di linate
per più di una settimana
ma prima di loro scoperto che un certo
nè druda era un semplice operaio tessile
inglese
ebbene passato alla storia questo
ragazzo proprio per la sua opposizione
violenta all'introduzione delle
tecnologie che avrebbero distrutto posti
di lavoro lui lavorava nel tessile e lui
si ribellò all'introduzione dei telai
tessili che avrebbero meccanizzato il
processo produttivo beh oggi distanza di
tempo era la fine del settecento
illudi smo e suo movimento ha perso la
sua battaglia e vero la tecnologia ha
distrutto tanti posti di lavoro però
pensiamoci bene lavori a basso valore
aggiunto lavori ripetitivi faticosi
pericolosi ma soprattutto nel lungo
termine una tecnologia creato nuova
occupazione
nuova occupazione a più alto valore
aggiunto che ha saputo valorizzare la
creatività umana e che permesso una
grande evoluzione dell'industria tessile
la stessa cosa avvenuto in altri settori
io stesso oggi a 40 anni di distanza vi
assicuro che non ho nessuno ma proprio
nessuno rimpianto dei tanti lavori che
faceva in agricoltura con il fratello
lavoro che facevo col badile col
falcetti in mezzo alla polvere e che la
tecnologia eliminato
allora come ci poniamo è come se fossimo
davanti a un bivio da una parte forse il
rifiuto della tecnologia non è la
soluzione migliore ma allora come
possiamo con serenità aprirci al
cambiamento
ad accettare di uscirne nelle nostre
zone di sicurezza con l'aspettativa e la
speranza di rimanere rilevanti nel nuovo
lavoro con l'aspettativa e la speranza
per quel che mi riguarda di mantenere un
tenore di vita che ci permetta di
portare i nostri figli era laurea o di
pagare un mutuo
guardate io nella mia vita ci sono
riuscito anno inventarmi più volte ci
sono tre cose tre cose che ho capito è
oggi voglio provare a condividere con
tutti voi
la prima introduco con una metafora
quanti di voi hanno imparato l'italiano
per poi diventare scrittori una minima
parte per tutti noi e l'italia ne è
stato una competenza che ci ha permesso
di accedere ad altre competenze con
l'italiana ho fatto ragioneria ha fatto
altri studi non ho mai fatto libri
allo stesso modo oggi io vi invito a
vedere la tecnologia non dovete pensare
a capirvi la tecnologia vuol dire
diventare sviluppatori di software no
oggi noi la tecnologia dobbiamo
comprendere studiare capirne i punti di
forza i limiti non per diventare
sviluppatori ma per comprendere le
trasformazioni in atto per summer ci
muove con agilità in ambito digitale
noi siamo nati in un mondo dove noi
dovevamo conoscere i computer oggi
entriamo in un mondo dove computer
conosceranno noi
torniamo a cambiare il nostro rapporto
con la tecnologia la tecnologia fino a
ieri è stata per noi una semplice
opportunità sempre di più domani il
nostro futuro sarà una necessità
ma questo primo aspetto ci porta subito
al secondo aspetto
che le tecnologie cambiano cambiano
velocemente
e allora è necessario una continua
capacità di adattamento di evoluzione di
sviluppo delle nostre competenze
capacità proprio in inglese chiamano
rischi l'ing
mandate la mia generazione è nata con
l'idea che la vita poteva dividersi in
due grandi fasi la fase dello studio
fino a 28 anni 29 e poi la fase del
lavoro o mi sistemo queste fassino quasi
sequenziale prima si studiava poi si
lavorava per 40 45 anni non è più così
queste due fasi da sequenziali devono
diventare parallele sovrapposte e
impensabile oggi impostare una carriera
professionale senza
senza una continua attività di
manutenzione delle nostre competenze
quando smisi di fare l'agricoltore la
mia azienda agricola era vicino a san
donato milanese 16 in a milano vicino a
san donato cileni passavo quella mia
moto
mandai il curriculum mi chiamarono per
un colloquio
ricordo ancora era un ragazzino 18 19
anni mi chiesero perché volevo entrare
all'eni di sposi in maniera forse un po
furbetta che volevo conoscere il mondo
volevo conoscere settore dell'energia
dentro di me a quell'età l'aspirazione
era un altro io giocavo con mio fratello
pallone e il nostro campo di san siro
era il campo di metanopoli della snam
il mio sogno di giocare su quel campo
non di girare il mondo sogno che poi
sono riuscito a realizzare questo ero io
a 18 anni
però vedete quelle esperienze di lavoro
mi ha fatto capire quello che mi disse
mio padre io ero stato agricoltore per
tanti anni è di nuovo un mio minimo di
rilevanza nel lavoro che facevo in
quella grande struttura era una
matricola non riuscivo incidere non nero
rilevante è lì e lì ho capito che per
colmare il gap con gente semplicemente
più brava e preparata di ne yo li dovevo
studiare e ho continuato a studiare e
continui studiare tuttora e lì ho capito
che ciò che non si rigenera degenera
però vedete
se tutta la vita dobbiamo continuare a
cambiare per c'è la tecnologia dobbiamo
continuare a studiare ma che vita è
soprattutto se lo facciamo con la
preoccupazione è l'unica preoccupazione
di poter perdere il posto di lavoro e
triste allora c'è una terza dimensione
molto importante che la capacità di
appassionarci al lavoro che facciamo di
appassionarci alle aziende che troviamo
di appassionarci alle persone che
troviamo soprattutto quando nella vita
vi sarà capitato e capiterà tutti
incontrate quei maestri del sapere con
persone sono persone di grande
esperienza di grande capacità
innamoratevi seguiteli fatevi
contaminare dalla loro conoscenza e
alimentate la vostra passione di
imparare
avete capito che la mia vita a queste
tre cose apertura al cambiamento
aggiornamento
e la passione sono stati tre elementi
che mi hanno permesso più volte di
uscire dalla mia zona di sicurezza sono
stato agricoltore impiegato consulente
oggi manager ma in tutti i lavori che ho
fatto io sono sempre stato rilevante
appagato dell'attività che facevano
queste cose
queste cose io però non avrei mai capito
se quel giorno da quel letto di ospedale
mio padre non avesse lanciato quel
salvagente dandomi fiducia e spronandoli
a costruirmi una professionalità e
studiare
per questo io mi sento nella mia
sfortuna un ragazzo fortunato più
fortunato di tanti altri oggi io avevo
il piacere di condividere con lo voi con
i miei figli con i miei nipoti quello
che la vita vi ha realmente insegnato
permettetemi però anche di scusarmi
quindi mi ragazzi federico sofia ma
siete qui a seguire papa oggi è oggi per
la prima volta avete capito
avete capito che il papa non è solo
quella del 110 e lode della bocconi ma
avete capito che papà avuto tante
debolezze come voi il papa è anche
quello che sto bocciato due volte
poi anche quello che accetto primo
lavoro per giocare su quel campo di
calcio
papa è anche quello che solo oggi che
avete 16 18 anni ho avuto il coraggio di
dirmelo
la vita riserverà tutti noi cambiamenti
in difficoltà momenti di grandi
opportunità
io sono fermamente convinto che un
approccio aperto appassionato al lavoro
ci possa permettere qualsiasi onda
affronteremo di sor fare sui cambiamenti
affrontando con fiducia e positività le
sfide che la vita ci riserverà
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì